congratulations yet another movie of
yours that I can't stop
watching well that's very good that's
the idea all right big broad question to
start here can you tell me something
about your writing process that stays
consistent from Project to project but
then also something unique to poor
things that demanded you do something
different uh what STS this well I'm
nothing but boring process um I use a
yellow legal pad and a particular blue
pen and I can't really write if I
haven't got those um no matter what it
is and
then poor things
particular I think with poor things what
I don't usually do
is trying to
think probably I with this one I watched
my kids a little bit because I had
little kids at the time and
so and B early in the first when she's
like a toddler I was just watching them
to see how what they were like because
we have ideas of kids and I wrote an
idea of what she would be and she was
too nice and then I looked at my kids
and they were like I'm gonna punch that
baby because it's crying and I was like
and Yos even said I told him that story
he's like we need to put that in the
movie because she needs a bit of Cruelty
CU kids are a bit Instinct and so so I
think that I don't usually look at my
own kids to think about the movie that
line is absolutely perfect it's
perfectly written and delivered where
it's one of those things where you start
laughing and then you worry that you
can't stop and 10 minutes later you're
still laughing about the joke that
happened a while
ago I
know all right so now I love hearing
about how things evolve along the way so
a couple of questions about that first
can you pinpoint the character that
changed the most after the RO was cast
oh after the RO was cast ah yeah well we
don't
really it doesn't really work that way
he doesn't no one gets the
script like no one gets the script until
it's ready like we worked on it I mean
Emma got it but she was the first person
to get like I would say it was four
years so literally by the time the
scripts by the time he casts the scripts
it's going to change like 2% you know so
he doesn't really there isn't really an
evolution in that way the only ution was
because Emma was on as a producer early
was that was she was part of the
conversation about the movie and Balor
and how it would look and who would be
in it and you know so we were in that
conversation so I guess Emma coming on
was an evolution in the movie because it
enhanced the movie it elevated
everything we were kind of trying to do
I'm curious now if there's an answer at
this stage of the process is there a
particular scene that evolved the most
from script to screen where what was
happening on set just took took it in a
direction that you all didn't anticipate
no because I think what's I think yogos
is a
very
um meticulous person so there's a lot of
freedom on set
but there isn't like he's very and he's
free with the actors but is there's
something about it that it's very him
and he's already there you know and
they're free and he he sees things later
that he didn't know they were doing and
but in the moment very like this three
weeks rehearsal which isn't to land
anything it's just fun and then but once
they're on set he's sort of very
intuitive and but he also knows he takes
a long we take a long time to do
everything so it's like four five years
with the scribs and not all the time we
have six months off all the time and
don't do anything um but then it's very
meticulous the process you know so by
the time he gets on set I mean I've done
two movies with him and each Chang
not much you know and maybe occasionally
he'll reblock something and we'll move
some words but it's a very meticulous
process I feel like you need that
quality when tackling an ambitious
project like this with so many layers
and elements to it um one more question
about the evolution of a film because in
addition to it evolving from from script
to screen it evolves again when it lands
in the audience's hand so is there
anything about the audience reaction to
the film that's surprised you and maybe
even shown you that something in your
own work is even stronger than you ever
thought it was uh I think well well what
can I say you know it's it's with great
relief people like it that's my biggest
takeway even though I know people
there's some people who it's not for
them which is it's a pretty unique film
so that's always was always going to be
the case so I think I'm very happy that
overall people really love it and I
think for me I think uh I think the
thing that's been gratifying is a lot of
women have felt seen by the movie in
some way and felt like the movie spoke
to them which is you know I'm I'm a guy
so that has felt good because I was like
I will somehow we wrote something I
wrote something that felt true and that
for a writer is a really good thing so
incredibly accurate right there everyone
that I've been speaking to has had that
kind of reaction and then I feel like
when the reaction is on the other side
it makes it more exciting because if
everybody likes a movie it's probably
not all that interesting 100% you've got
to have 15 to 20% like this is awful it
makes me angry yeah I like an exciting
conversation like that all right so it
is uh it's pretty incredible how
expertly you weave together so many
things in this film from like the bizaar
the humor uh heartbreak with a
significant amount of thematic heft to
it can you give me an example of a
particular scene that Pro most difficult
when striking that balance yeah there
was probably a couple let me see which
one I think probably the last scene the
dinner table scene with Alfie when she
goes back to her
husband was difficult on a number of
levels a I was nervous because it's
weird to bring in a new character to El
or movie who's going to be like very
intrinsic so that seemed kind of risky
but also it was I knew it was darker
than where we had been so I was like how
do we keep the comedy how do we keep but
sort of
unhinged and also make it feel emotional
so I was like and then I came up with
the idea of a it's not in the book but
she does in she didn't she never chooses
to go back there it's a different ending
but I was like she should choose because
she's fearless to go find out where it
was and then once she's there I you know
I was like oh well how do I make it like
funny and then I was like oh maybe
there's he's this weird guy and he's got
a weird codependence with with his
servants and they're having an uprising
and you know and so I was just sort of
like how do we make it odd and funny
like the rest of the movie but in a
slightly darker way so you're a bit
unnerved by the whole thing so that was
a tricky scene for me to kind of wrangle
I guess to get the right pitch on used
the word unhinged and it made me think
of this is there any particular thing
you wrote that is so unhinged that you
thought there is no way anyone's G to
let us do this but now it's in the
finished film yeah I
I think when I wrote The Crab guy in the
brothel the guy just scuttles across the
room and doesn't do anything else I was
bit
like I thought it was funny because we
wanted sort of you know I didn't just I
wanted the broth to be sort of have some
oddness to it and and the whole point of
the storytelling beat in it was she just
sh seeing the array of human desire and
weird humans and so I didn't
want it to be all sex so I but I was at
that point like I don't know that
they're going to do the crab guy but
then the good thing with yogos is he's
got final carton it's all on so what he
wants you know BR bring on the weird
bring on all the crab guys you want I
here for it I'll wrap up with h one
question about Emma because obviously
she excels in everything she's in and I
look forward to talking about how damn
good she is in this movie for weeks and
months to come yeah you obviously know
how talented she is but is there
anything she does in this movie that
made you stop and
I knew you were good but I never
realized you were capable of doing that
yeah I think so I mean I my opinion of
it was pretty high to begin with so you
know I think I always thought she's
extraordinary she grounds everything
she's emotional she's funny I think I
was just like her choices were really
great were really bold and I I think
when I wrote the first draft of this and
we didn't know who was going to do it I
was like who can who can do this because
the arc is so huge and and I I think to
watch the meticulousness with which she
did that and yet it still feels wild and
organic but everything is landed piece
by piece that was extraordinary to me
because it's just Flawless it's there
isn't a piece out you know there isn't a
moment that's flawed or false or and it
just lands all the storytelling but
completely like organically like you
you're still on a wild ride that feels
completely out of
control but but watching it as a
Storyteller I'm like it's it's just Pace
by Pace put together beautifully so so
accurate and accurate across the board
exceptional movie on every single level
congratulations you deserve all the good
coming your way thank you very much it's
been fun to talk to
you